I have a million things to share about
working with James I feel like he never
really knew how good he was and I think
that may have served him or me or served
other people like he was so humble in
the face of how great he was he never
really felt like he knew what he was
doing and it may it can't help but make
you so comfortable and just and love him
so easily
because he was so such a powerful actor
such a powerful scene partner but the
humility added to just just how much
money was to be with me Jim was very
very funny we had a lot allows and he
took his work seriously but he didn't
take himself seriously you know what I
mean like he was willing to you know be
a clown and and you know have fun and
yet he could also be very generous very
giving he was there if you needed him
and leaving very good friends and that
made the work even better I think oh my
god be able to let loose and laugh where
he didn't have a heavy scene we did a
scene where we all played Marco Polo
late night in the pool and that was just
just to be like a silly family you know
but we didn't got many moments like that
I treasure those I have a lot of
favorite memories but I think the best
memory was when we were working on the
last scene that I was in and yeah was
just a lot of tears because it was my
last scene and and you know and
everybody was upset but you know when
the Emmys were announced I got a phone
call about 7:45 in the morning it was
Jimmy and he said Vinny you were robbed
because I didn't get nominated and for
him to call me up and say that I always
remember that phone call he said you
were robbed and you then you say to
yourself I don't think we're gonna get
this shot again you know as an actor I
mean it could come again but
and you know I thought about that and I
would have really loved to been
nominated you know but that's you know
what are you gonna do think about all
the time and very great good friends off
offset as well and you know this every
single thing I did with him you know you
walk away a better actor and and he was
just very very humble you know very much
in his own mind a character actor he
never really felt like a leading man you
know so that kept things in the more of
an ensemble I think that vibe you know
definitely the off-camera stuff about
you know finding out that he would call
my manager to make sure I wasn't
spending too much on rent or hanging out
with the wrong people this and him
telling my manager don't tell Robert I
called you didn't want the credit you
don't people to think it was a good guy
that's the thing like I don't remember
Jim ever going around looking for
validation from people you know he was
we was and for me Jim was perfect
[Music]